-You guys ever see a photo
in the news
and think, "That headline
should be different"?
Well, let's take care
of that right now.
It's time for "News and
Improved." Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
The headline
can definitely be improved,
because if you only looked
at the photo,
the headline could have been...
-Oh.
-You see how it works?
[ Applause ]
Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
It's affecting everyone.
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-Fireball.
[ Laughter ]
-This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
Aww.
[ Applause ]
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
I'm gonna see that.
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
-Wow.
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
That's Salt Bae.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-And finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...
There you have it, everybody.
That's all the time we have
for "News and Improved."
We have a great show.